in the next episode of Star talk it's a
cosmic queries all chemicals Edition my
co-host Matt kershen together we meet
and greet Kate the chemist this is Kate
bieberdorf from the University of Texas
at Austin
and she tells us all kinds of things in
response to our patreon questions for
example what is the only f word she does
not allow in her classroom that's kind
of interesting and can we use the
gaseous constituents of farts to decide
whether life exists on another planet
that's kind of freaky weird there and
did you know you can take an inert
element and make a molecule out of it I
didn't I learned in this episode so
stay with us check it out
[Music]
this is Star Talk Cosmic queries this is
a special chemicals Edition because
some of my best friends are made of
chemicals of course all of my best
friends are made of chemicals I got with
me my co-host Matt Kirsch and Matt how
you doing man
I'm good I've just found out I'm made of
chemicals that's a little bit worrying
but yeah sorry I meant I meant to warn
you in advance
dangerous yeah do we need to uh does
there need to be a warning does it need
to be yellow tape around me what's going
on what do we got hopefully we'll find
out
so I know a little bit of chemistry
because we needed an astrophysics but
not enough to be the source for this
show we comb the landscape and we
rediscovered Kate bieberdorf Kate
welcome back to Star talk thank you so
much for having me I'm so excited to be
back yeah Kate Kate we're you're you're
moniker your online moniker is Kate the
chemist and I love it you have a PhD in
chemistry and you're now associate
professor of instruction and of
chemistry at the University of Texas at
Austin so that's just the kind of
expertise we need when we comb our
patreon members uh who get exclusive
access to the questions on our Cosmic
queries so uh so Matt you've collected
them I haven't seen them I don't think
Kate
only Matt has seen these questions so
there are a lot of very good questions
it's gonna it's gonna I'm gonna try and
get through them all I apologize to any
patrons we uh patrons we don't get
through but uh because there's a lot of
good ones so let's kick off with Sora
and Saka asks at what point after the
big bang can we see chemistry came into
existence from the physics of the early
universe
whoa
what that's heavy yeah sorry to drop
that one right on you at the beginning
yeah tell us when you're in Playa feel
this study stuff
well let me let me tee up Kate here so
Kate my early universe is really really
really really hot and as we expand it
slowly cools
so
as I remember high temperatures are not
good for making molecules so what are
some molecules that you might make first
in the highest of temperatures as the
universe cools well in the very
beginning we really only had two
elements I mean we think that we only
had the two of hydrogen and helium and
that was the very beginning and the two
of those reacted together they kind of
existed together for quite a period of
time and after some time when the
universe started cooling down that's
when we were able to actually start the
molecules just like you were saying
because chemistry and the formation of
molecules is all about exchanging
electrons and so nuclear chemistry which
is what happens a lot in in space that's
about the the core the nucleus but
chemistry here on Earth is all about
electrons and so in order to form a bond
between two atoms we need to have some
kind of electron exchange so they're
either going to transfer electrons or
they're going to share their electrons
and unfortunately when some when the
temperatures are really really hot these
atoms can't even hold on to their
electrons so in the very beginning we
didn't really have a hydrogen and helium
atoms we we had the nucleus and so we
had a species with one proton or a
species with two protons and so once the
universe finally cools down that's when
we can start actually forming these
bonds between each other because the
atoms can now hang on to their electrons
so a classic molecule that we just there
was like a big Hadoop about it a couple
years ago was the helium hydrogen
molecule that was formed so h e h plus
what yeah
no no that's not allowed no what do you
mean that's not allowed yeah
there's one thing I know about helium or
it's the squeaky voice thing but if
there's two things I know that it
doesn't form any any bonds with anything
so right now to make helium how magic
are you what sorcery are you committing
in the early Universe to make this
happen
well we have to have high temperatures
that's a big piece and so we have to
have enough and there's also velocity
component those are the two main pieces
so these two protons or these two
species have to slam into each other
with enough velocity and high enough
temperatures in order to basically have
that stronghold
oh okay got it all in all in I I thought
they were somehow the helium atom like
full up with its electrons was somehow
mating with a hydrogen atom to make a h
e h molecule okay now wow I was sweating
there for a minute okay no but it's just
usually in space we don't find very many
molecules because it's very difficult
that the the temperatures are unique the
the conditions are really unique and so
oftentimes we find species without their
electrons on them so we're not finding
full atoms we're finding these charged
ions and so in order to have the
molecule you really need to have that
atom component so we can have that
electron exchange it's fascinating stuff
it's wacky stuff it's here on Earth that
just doesn't happen like easily but I
don't get the nuclear stuff yeah the
nuclear exactly yeah we don't have
nuclear chemistry it's so we have just
regular old chemistry here on Earth but
there's a follow-up question from Sauron
that I think is related to this that is
um is it possible for the periodic table
of elements to be different in another
part of the universe with vastly
different conditions or do we need
another Universe with different
fundamental laws for that to happen oh I
love that question I do too so let me
give my answer and then Neil I want to
hear your answer to that if that's okay
sure because my answer would be no in
this universe we all have the same
building blocks we all started with the
hydrogen and the helium components
um and so we are going to then form the
exact same elements with the same
building box blocks when we change the
number of neutrons or protons or
electrons that a sample has so here in
our universe I personally think our
periodic table is locked in with these
elements we can discover new ones still
but I don't think we're going to have
completely different conditions yeah I
agree entirely do you agree yeah we get
we look at Spectra of
Stars galaxies Across the Universe and
the Spectrum matches what we can produce
in the laboratory for the various
chemical elements so you look at like
what carbon looks like sort of when you
burn it in a lab and it has a signature
in the Spectrum and you find that same
signature as you look out into the
universe so these all these same
elements are there so we have no reason
to think that the Periodic Chart would
look different at all and Kate uh plus
the the chart is full right I mean
there's no room left well I'd fight you
on that oh they're they're professors
yeah let's go so professor elginesson
over in California would absolutely
fight you on this and so he has been
responsible for the last like six or
seven elements that have been discovered
he is this fascinating technology
I get it okay so we're adding at the
extreme end but we're not yes Crow
barring other elements no that's all I
know that's all I meant yeah I agree
with you that the first like 100 18 are
locked in but after that we're still
forming new ones I mean we could even go
to another row on the periodic table I
don't know that I will ever see that
personally I'm optimistic that we will
but I don't know maybe like my like
great great great great great
grandchildren would see something like
that
and and are you just showing off why
does your chart behind you for those who
see this in video say periodic chart of
the atoms where everybody else just says
periodic chart of the elements so do you
know something that you don't know no
this is just an old one oh Lucy was a
Dayton
1924. so this came from 1924. it's
interesting
did they have all the information then
or is there like as kind of heavy
dragons area
it it's wacky when I first got this
periodic table my husband and I stared
at it for 30 minutes it was like the
best date we've ever had because we're
both chemists you're like looking at it
it was so cool because
because they talk about where the
electrons are in the shells it's just a
different way of organizing the
information and so here all of it is put
into the elements little box whereas on
our periodic table now it's organized in
that very specific structure so you have
the two on top and then it kind of looks
like that bowl right and so mine doesn't
look like that anymore because it
doesn't we don't organize them that way
plus 1924 we were in the middle of
discovering quantum physics right this
decade is the Centennial anniversary
decade of quantum physics which gave a
full understanding of what the hell's
going on on the periodic table so I I'm
so I love classic old stuff thanks for
sharing sharing that information with us
I think this segue is quite neatly into
the question from Scott bringlow AKA
Scott the pilot who has two
granddaughters who are curious and
science curious granddaughters young
kids firstly says can you say hi to
Beatrice and Louisa hi Beatrice hi
Louisa okay and Scott's very grateful to
have a grown community of female role
models in science and also asks uh Scott
was wondering about combining atoms
under normal Earthly conditions and then
about where in the universe atoms
combined because of extreme conditions
of temperature operation perhaps where
do we find strange compounds that would
not exist on Earth so you've already
just you've already discussed this a bit
with hydrogen helium combining well okay
but that would be a nuclear fusion but I
got a good one for you okay
um so Kate we learned in in chemistry
class that hydrogen
is sometimes a metal
right like it's on both sides of the
periodic table which was kind of freaky
to me and I didn't fully understand that
until I took astrophysics so do they
teach how it is that hydrogen can become
a metal in The Collector you teach it in
your classes not in general chemistry no
that's a little Advanced right that's
what I'm saying it wasn't really there
yeah not not in your basic classes you
really learned more about that when you
go into the lab so I my first
introduction to it was when I used
lithium aluminum hydride and my graduate
student was like okay this could kill
you so let's have a conversation about
it and it's like okay
yeah exactly half the stuff on the table
could kill you but usually it has to do
with the charge on the atom so when
hydrogen is negatively charged it can
behave more like a metal whereas when
hydrogen is positively charged it
operates more like the gas itself and we
have the cool properties that you
probably are familiar with because it's
similar to what would happen on the
universe in space right so in the core
of Jupiter under very very high pressure
Jupiter has is mostly hydrogen and
helium it's gaseous it's damn near like
a star in its composition and the helium
but the hydrogen in the core under very
extreme pressures creates the metallic
properties of the hydrogen and those
metallic properties then create enabled
dynamos to form which creates a very
strong magnetic field so Earth has a
magnetic field because we have an iron
core and that itself is magnetic but
Jupiter has a magnetic core because of
what it's done to hydrogen and and
that's when I first saw hydrogen
or a new of a place where hydrogen
behaved this way under natural causes oh
that's right so that kind of relates
Joey Santos us I'm just going to combine
this for uh are there any theorized
molecules that are only made possible to
exist outside of the bonds of this
planet due to Cosmic phenomena or some
sort that we can't re that we can't
recreate and I'm wondering actually
because that second part of the question
it sounds like it might not happen
naturally but some of these things can
be recreated under extreme lab
conditions yeah once you know how you
can create it I got one in the universe
but Kate do you do you have any uh were
there any that eluded us until our lab
experiments got better
oh absolutely so like Xenon we thought
Xenon was an inert gas forever it is in
the periodic table it's a couple below
helium so we would expect for it to be a
nerd but once we got into the lab we
were actually able to make xef4
um so put four fluorines on it and that
was that was shocking people were not
expecting that at all because you
thought it was an inert gas but it turns
out it's only in there under certain
conditions what's the one in the
universe you have wait wait so so that
okay that reminds me Kate so the
properties that we list for your 118
elements we all have to agree under what
condition those properties are being
reported right so so if we say it's
liquid
well it's only liquid in a certain
temperature range so it's not natively
liquid
it's just happens to be liquid because
we're measuring it in our own Labs at 72
degrees right so how do you understand
so 25 Celsius 25 Celsius I got to throw
that in there no excuse me okay
25 Celsius excuse me so you use
Fahrenheit that's like the only f word I
don't allow in my classroom I'll take
everything else
so someone could say Celsius and that's
just fine
I don't care
that's funny because they're more of a
Kelvin fan what are we doing here can I
ask um
okay so I guess what I'm saying is on
the chart where you have room
temperature at 25 degrees Celsius that
to say something is a liquid reported as
a property of the element it kind of
doesn't make sense
to report properties of elements unless
you have a full discussion under what
conditions you are measuring those
properties isn't that right yeah that's
an excellent point and so we always talk
about STP so standard temperature and
pressure and so in general if we don't
say otherwise it is safe to assume we
are under the conditions of 25 degrees
Celsius which is like Loosely room
temperature and then a pressure of one
atmosphere which is again the Loosely
the pressure on Earth and so in my class
I say this all the time like we are only
studying the things on earth so that's
why we use these conditions and then
when we move to astrochemistry that's
when we take ourselves off of Earth and
move into the universe where it's more
nuclear chemistry whereas on Earth it's
more chemistry chemistry like
traditional chemistry all right and so
and one more thing Matt and then I'll
then I'll hand it back you can have the
the speakers Mallet or whatever what do
they pass around in the microphone
okay the early version of the microphone
was I think was a speaker stone or
something you couldn't speak unless you
had the stick the speaker's stick oh
yeah so a friend of mine from the UK
noted for me that there's an element
that is solid in the UK but liquid in
the United States
gallium
maybe it was gallium because in in the
UK their room temperature was colder
than in the United States
so what's the melting point of gallium
it's 30 degrees Celsius so just a little
bit warmer than room temperature okay so
which is 85 degrees Fahrenheit for the
Americans yeah we can totally yeah
there's plenty of places that are 85
here in the United States that actually
was throwing me because I seem to
remember from school chemistry that we
that 20 degrees Celsius was the
was room temperature that's 68 degrees
Fahrenheit no one would call that
um so hang on remembering from school
chemistry like
I thought all the noble gases were inert
because they've got full electron shells
so how do you get
for fluorine atoms onto onto one
first of all
specific job on that that is amazing
that you remember that they are full of
electron shells and that's why they're
not react
great job your high school teacher would
be so proud or whoever teaches a levels
of that
um but the the answer is extreme
conditions like that's always the answer
when it when you make something work
that you're not expecting to it's
extreme conditions and usually for us we
can alter pressure volume and
temperature and so if we do something at
a low volume then it's going to force
these atoms to interact and so for
chemistry it's all about collisions did
they Collide and did they have the
proper orientation so for example if I
have one thing that's horizontal and
another thing that's vertical and they
slam into each other it might not be a
favorable interaction but if they now
move around the flask a little bit more
and now they're both horizontal and they
slam into each other now they can
actually form that molecule so it has to
do with how they Collide and in what
orientation man it's more complicated
than I ever thought it's very
complicated yeah because you don't
necessarily have a reaction and just
because the molecules Collide you have
to have the proper conditions and high
pressure really helps that because it's
forcing those collisions to occur it's
forcing those atoms or molecules
depending on what you're studying to
actually go through those collisions
breaking bonds forming new bonds and you
just need to have those collisions in
the right orientation
all right we got to take a quick break
but when we come back more with Kate the
chemist in Cosmic queries the chemicals
Edition we'll be right back
we're back to our talk Cosmic queries
chemicals Edition with cake the chemist
all right we got Matt kirschen with us
reading us the questions so Matt yeah to
me Don lane from Michigan says I
recently read an article about how the
asteroid is it pronounced rygu
r-y-u-g-u was full of organic molecules
what does that mean for possible life in
the galaxy
yeah I mean uh you know when we we
looked out in the universe wondering
whether life was rare and then we find
the building blocks of life everywhere
so Kate how important do you think if so
let me say that differently if these
asteroids and comets hit Earth
delivering these basic ingredients
um what more do you need to give us life
I mean that's that's the basic part of
it right is you need the main things
that our bodies are comprised of so you
need the carbons you need your hydrogens
in our personal human body we also need
oxygen that's the number one thing we
need and so we were able to sustain life
here on Earth because of its atmosphere
I mean it is 21 oxygen even though it's
primarily nitrogen that oxygen on Earth
is what we need to sustain life so if we
were to have life over on other planets
somewhere else in the universe depending
on what that I'm just going to say human
but whatever their body is whatever
their species is they are going to have
something else that they need in order
to breathe and function and so maybe
it's not oxygen maybe it's nitrogen
because their system operates a little
bit differently
okay so but you're saying it's it's
necessary to have these ingredients but
maybe it's not sufficient we need some
other things going on in other words if
if you just have a tide pool with all
the right ingredients will some creature
crawl out given enough time or do we not
know enough about that transition to to
say at this point
I do not think we know enough about that
transition but I do think that when we
have atoms around each other under the
right conditions like like the extreme
conditions a lot of things can happen I
mean we're very far away from doing
crazy nuclear chemistry here on Earth
but we can see out in the universe that
when you're at high temperature and when
you have high velocity really
fascinating molecules can form so it
really just depends on the conditions
and you know how close that particular
planet is to their Sun are they really
close is it very hot because you're
going to have different reactivity than
if we're at something like Pluto which
is really really far away from the Sun
completely different chemistry that also
kind of connects to uh listen to Kenneth
from Atlanta who says we talk about the
Goldilocks zone the importance of liquid
water and other chemicals in the
periodic table that could be analogs to
the biochemistry on Earth but are there
any molecule sorry models that
investigate biochemistry based on
completely different temperature scales
and different phases of matter so I
think that relates to what you were
talking about with these different
conditions on these different yeah yeah
Kate what is STP on another planet can
can you do you guys think about
pot life under those very different
conditions maybe not liquid water but
yeah Kenneth says exactly that he says
what might there be different chemicals
in liquid form that could serve as a
metabolite on different and what gases
could be breathed right I saw a comic
from The New Yorker where there's
there's uh aliens that just crash landed
in the desert and they're pulling
themselves along the the the desert
floor and they're saying ammonia ammonia
yes
so can you imagine that Kate yes I can I
can see a system based off of nitrogen
so our system here on Earth is typically
pretty heavy in carbon hydrogen and
oxygen like those are big pieces and so
something that is just a neighbor of
that is nitrogen and so it would not be
that unusual for me to see or to to
I guess to believe that we could have
other life forms that are dependent on
nitrogen so maybe they breathe nitrogen
gas maybe they need to drink ammonia
because that's what works in their
system but foreign
exactly yeah and but I think a huge part
of it just to go back to what you said
about STP is here on Earth as we do have
an atmosphere and so we do have all
these gases that are pushing down on us
and we have chemical reactions based on
that but in other planets they don't
have the atmosphere so they don't even
have that pressure so what people would
people but what that life form would be
breathing in or not that's what's weird
for me I have a hard time with that
piece because like how would that work
if there's no atmosphere so for me I
personally believe that if there is life
in other places there's got to be an
atmosphere in order for those natural
chemical reactions to occur what do you
think
yeah I think or it can happen uh
underground right I mean you can have
pressures underground where you don't
have to worry about what's above ground
in fact I did I just recently learn this
Kate you're closer to this than I am in
the biology world that there may be a
greater biomass beneath Earth's surface
than above it I heard that too edit it
up do you do you this is something you
remember from biology literature I
remember hearing about that yeah I just
heard about it right but if that's true
that's that's just amazing right it
meant here we are thinking how important
the surface is and sunlight and this and
that and it's like no most organisms
don't give a rat's ass about the surface
and but what that also means is judging
whether Mars has life should not be a
conversation about how hostile the
surface is to life
and tell me I'm going to slip this in
Matt do I have permission to put in a
question
uh granted okay thank you
um we learned that ultraviolet light
which which is not shielded on Mars from
the Sun is hostile to
to biology what what is going on there
what is it what is the ultraviolet why
is it hostile to anything at all if it's
just light
well it's hostile here on Earth I mean
the ultraviolet light is what causes
skin cancer and so it's such high energy
radiation that it actually can kick off
electrons off of atoms and so in our
electromagnetic spectrum our weakest
energy is going to be radio and
microwaves then you have infrared and
then your visible region and then
directly on top of that that's where
your ultraviolet kicks in and so your
ultraviolet your X-ray your gamma rays
those three main categories are such
high energy radiation that they can spit
that electron off of the atom and when
that happens in our body that's what
causes skin cancer and so we really need
to wear a sunscreen because essentially
we have sacrificial molecules that we
put on top of our skin that die they
split okay they split their bond split
and that's what protects us because
those molecules die and then the
ultraviolet radiation essentially goes
to those molecules you're saying the
sunscreen is your sacrificial Shield yep
interesting yeah
I didn't realize I thought it sort of
just bounces it in some way I didn't
realize it kind of works almost like a
like a bike helmet where it just breaks
instead of your head it's sunscreen
versus sunblock and so sunscreen has
molecules in there that essentially
absorb the ultraviolet radiation and
when that happens their bonds break and
now they're no longer active they can no
longer protect you and so you only have
X amount of molecules you put on your
body and so when you run out of those
sacrificial molecules now you're just
exposed you're just sitting there with
the UV radiation hitting your your skin
yeah damn right so so my clothing would
be a sunblock correct
yeah it's a physical blocker and so the
sun block is like a physical blocker so
for those you're using nail particles
um and yeah like zinc or
titanium interesting but wait a minute
Kate yes we get that that UV causes skin
cancer but there are UV Chambers in
hospitals that sterilize uh surgical
equipment and we're not asking whether
those microbes are getting skin cancer
so what what else is what else is the UV
doing it's the same thing it's splitting
the molecules and so if you have
essentially bad molecules on you know
your your scalpel or whatever it is
they're going to use in the hospital
you're killing the bacteria and you can
actually use UV radiation to do that
when covid-19 kind of came out they
weren't sure in the very beginning if UV
was going to be strong enough they did a
lot of research and they found out that
we could actually use UV radiation to
kill the covid-19 piece and so that's
that's kind of so here's the the virus
um getting skin cancer
the basic molecular structure of the
virus is the UV is bust busting it open
okay the important part not every Bond I
don't want to imply every Bond but the
important parts that make it dangerous
it breaks those bonds into basically
make that virus no longer active and so
that's what sterilizes very good very
good okay thank you I slipped my
question and then I'm not even a patreon
member how do you like that I know I
know you're shameful shameful the real
patrons are going to be furious okay an
interluder is sneaking in yeah Therese
Talbot from Columbia South Carolina says
are there any places in space where we
cannot go due to reactions between a
Rocket's exhaust and potentially
volatile chemicals in surrounding space
I would say tentatively no because
usually space is the absence of
molecules and so I feel okay saying that
there are protons moving around I feel
okay saying that there are some atoms in
some areas but in terms of having really
big molecules that are going to have
reactions that's kind of limited now all
that being said when we have and you
know you're gonna have to fine-tune this
but when we have supernovas that explode
or they do their thing then we can throw
out those poly aromatic hydrocarbons and
those are out there and we know that
those can have reactivity but in general
those are mostly stable
so there's no need to strap a canary to
the front of the rocket no you would die
for other reasons I think
uh it has to die for the reason you had
in mind so I'm just thinking uh in the
app in the empty space of course Kate
that's right there's no there's nothing
for your exhaust to interact with so
it'll just stay there as exhaust but it
had to take off
from Earth's surface at some point or
some other planet surface that might
have had an atmosphere so we can ask
does it interact with Earth's atmosphere
when it launches and I can tell you that
the main Rockets not the solid rocket
boosters but the main large engines are
just hydrogen and oxygen
in liquid state and they're brought
together with these valves and and Kate
tell us what happens when we combine
hydrogen and oxygen we have a very
beautiful combustion reaction and so
this is clean energy and so hydrogen is
an excellent source of fuel it releases
something like 286 kilojoules per mole
of hydrogen it's a beautiful source of
fuel and it doesn't have any carbon okay
so hydrogen by itself doesn't have
carbon so it doesn't release carbon
dioxide and that's why it's very clean
and green and we're not contributing to
climate change yeah so the rockets that
you see with all their plumes the
exhaust most of that exhaust is just
water vapor I guess right I mean yeah
that's that's my understanding of it
yeah yeah I don't want to go and breathe
it like while that's happening because I
think I will get cooked but right right
there's no other chemical another
different chemicals in this solid rocket
boosters but our mainstay
if throttle engines or hydrogen and
oxygen and Kate isn't that what they're
talking about as another energy source
for cars oh yeah absolutely how real is
that I mean speaking as a chemist
I so I am optimistic I would love for
that to happen what I get nervous about
is in general how would we do that and
so do you strap a hydrogen tank to the
back of your car so like the logistics
of it makes me extraordinarily nervous
these are called cells I guess right
that the fuel cell well yeah yeah you
would you would likely use a fuel cell
in this and so you would need some kind
of way to constantly input hydrogen so a
fuel cell is a cell or a battery
depending on how you want to talk about
it where you're constantly introducing
your source of fuel and so you would
need a source of hydrogen what I would
love to see is if we would find a way to
kind of do that safely so that we could
burn hydrogen on our cars without
producing carbon dioxide to me though
from my understanding of it that just
seems like a logistical nightmare so let
me remind people that the Hindenburg was
kept afloat by hydrogen okay so if you
have a tank of hydrogen uh well maybe
it's not worse than a tank of gasoline I
mean I don't know I'd have to yeah we'd
have to no spoilers but how did it go
oh with for the Hindenburg yeah no yeah
yeah it no
yeah that didn't end well for the for
the Hindenburg Matt so let's see if we
can slip one more question in before we
take a break okay I'm gonna I'm gonna be
cheeky and and combine two questions
because they're both about iron Thomas
Cochran who's also a hematologist so
really really entire and I'm very happy
to see Kate the chemist returning says I
think iron is pretty neat I also learned
iron is responsible for the deaths of
the largest stars of the universe what
is the unique chemical characterization
of iron that makes it consume energy
when it undergoes Fusion or fission and
then fatty Hayek says we learn from Neil
that the fusion process when stars form
ends with the thud in Iron so how come
there are heavier elements on Earth
where did they come from oh oh I think
those are two quite those are two
questions that I think are playing in
the same point in it well okay we don't
have time in this segment we can put a
pin in that and when we come back more
Cosmic queries the chemicals Edition
keep the chemist be right back
we're back StarTalk Cosmic queries
chemicals Edition with Kate the chemist
who is an associate professor of
chemistry and science instruction at UT
Austin and Kate you now host a podcast
that is about to drop that's sponsored
by NPR national public radio so what's
that about
I'm so excited to announce this um it's
called seeking a scientist the first
episode drops in April and it's
basically my dream job I get to
interview scientists doing cool cool
science and highlight their amazing
research and we're really focusing on
unique things that you might not know
that much about and so of course we're
going to tackle the fungus zombies we've
got to talk about that
um there's some new research out where
you can reverse aging so you can
actually reset a heart by 10 years so
we're talking the scientists doing that
so it's just absolutely fascinating
research and my goal is to just turn
scientists into rock stars excellent
excellent especially if the this the
science they're doing directly affects
people's lives oh my gosh all of a
sudden people will start caring about
them in ways they never thought that any
of us thought was possible so
congratulations on that we look forward
maybe you can come back and tell us uh
yeah we'll totally get you back to talk
about some of who you interview and and
math how did you do that okay totally
and Matt you're you're still hosting
probably science correct I am yeah so
that's yeah that's still going on uh so
yeah I I love it when we found a bunch
of listeners thanks to you and your show
so hi excellent Mutual listeners
was it 30 years ago I was a guest on
your show open invitation anytime
you don't call you know right you know
oh the the second you need a 0.01 bump
in your book sales
so what goes on on your on your on your
show Well normally we go through the
weekend science news with other
comedians so we get comics on we talk
about what's been happening we riff with
them and then every so often we do
special episodes where we have real
scientists on or science writers and
communicators and then and we talk about
them and their work so okay cool Neil
was a very special episode all right
well thank you a very sweet of you all
right so we're getting back into that
question you left off with it was from a
hematologist how often do you get a a
conversation with a hematologist uh I
guess that's blood right and uh an iron
specifically an iron yeah exactly iron
specifically and he was trying to get
all up in the the astrophysical
situation for iron and Kate the we know
in astrophysics that the buck stops an
iron when you're fusing elements
it's exothermic until iron and
afterwards it's endothermic and then
when you're fissioning elements
it's exothermic down to iron and you try
to Fizz iron then it's endothermic so
what's going on with iron that
chemically in the nucleus
and follow up from fatty how how does
how do we get things that aren't Iron as
well in on Earth
okay so my understanding of the iron
component is like you said it's an
energy piece it's not necessarily
specifically iron or the fact that it
has you know X Y or Z but it has to do
with the nuclear binding energy and so
binding energy depending on what type of
scientist you talk to you're going to
get a different definition but when in
my world what it means is how tightly
those protons and neutrons and electrons
are held into that atom so how easily
can you split that atom apart into its
components and so iron has a really high
binding energy and so those protons
electrons neutrons are really held into
that atom nickel is right next door to
it and so my understanding of this is
that you can actually generate some
nickel but then it radioactively decays
back to iron and so in general when we
get to iron it's like we've run out of
fuel and so hydrogen you can use helium
you can use carbon you can use oxygen
silicon all of these you can use and you
can generate more fuel for the sun I'll
just call this sun you can generate more
fuel and so it can keep doing its thing
but once you hit iron now you cannot
change the atom structure as easily you
cannot force iron to turn into another
atom as easily because it takes too much
energy and so essentially it starts to
implode and then you kind of just crash
out so but in a supernova explosion
um there's so much energy available that
it doesn't matter that your your
endothermic you can absorb energy and
there's still plenty of energy around so
we can visit the heavier elements in the
periodic table but only when you have so
much excess us energy that it didn't
matter that you ate some of it and so
yeah that's how you get right on up to
uranium yeah we're good there so I'm
going to combine beer and amine beer and
brat and and Bjorn uh ferric nap I hope
I pronounced that correctly uh because
they've all asked questions about is
there a limit to the amount of elements
that can be in the periodic table how
you go about updating it
um whether you can discover new ones out
there and Bjorn wants to know whether
there is a maximum possible size whether
you could even have an element that is
the size Beyonce says of a Toyota
Corolla oh I love that yeah so Kate uh
when where does it end we're up to what
118 now you said at the beginning yeah
we have 118 elements right now on the
periodic table uh there's one Professor
who's been really driving the new
formation of new elements they're
extraordinarily unstable like they exist
for less than a second so it's
unbelievably hard to characterize them
and prove that you've made this element
you need high-tech equipment you to all
these things and so it's very difficult
for other places to replicate it so
right now currently in 2023 I would say
that the most
possible chance of us having new
elements would be because of organism in
California because he just keeps sending
neutrons at different elements in
different conditions to see what he can
come up with and it's absolutely
fascinating research so I I read that if
you go a little heavier maybe into the
120s 120 number of protons that we might
have an island of stability how real is
that or is that just Oz off in the
distance and maybe it's not real we just
wish it were real where the element will
last longer than a zillionth of a second
I don't know I don't know it really is
going to depend on how many protons are
going to be in the core and more
importantly where the electrons are
sitting in the outer shell so
I don't know I but you've heard about
this right so you're skeptical what
you're saying is that I eat them I am
and it's just because our current
research doesn't support that like at
all and so I understand why I understand
why there's a thought about that in it
the position in the periodic table would
absolutely affect that so I do
understand that
I just that seems so far-fetched for me
that it's just it's one step outside of
it for for my personal Comfort I wanted
a fistful of element 125 whatever that
would be and walk around me too me too
someday
all right Matt Keep It Coming how many
can we finish okay uh Tom B Knight who's
also a science fiction writer wants to
know what is the most powerful chemical
explosive and is it possible we would
discover something more powerful what
elements or compounds would you start
with if doing this research and that
feels like both a Sci-Fi writer's
question and also something every kid in
chemistry class wants yeah
I'll tell you what makes the biggest
bangs cool all right Kate what is it oh
hysterical I get asked that question all
the time so that's very funny
um so we don't necessarily have like one
that's the most explosive one molecule
here on Earth right now but in general
what I can say you about tell you about
these molecules is they typically have
nitrogen in them
um not nitrogen with triple bonds bound
to each other other but there are
nitrogen placed across the molecule a
lot of times it's like in a nitrate form
and so those are usually what is quite
explosive interesting and in TNT comes
from nitrogen I guess right yes it does
yep exactly all right because today when
we measure the strength of nuclear
blasts it's in units of TNT so that kind
of feels like we're maxing out on on
sticks of dynamite or if Dynamite well
Dynamite I don't think not technically
the same as TNT at least slightly
different I heard is that right well
it's a composition because Dynamite has
other stuff in there to try to keep it
stable until you want it to react right
and so there's so you're not just like
walking around with actual try Nitro
toluene that would be incredibly
dangerous something to kind of stable
you're going to walk around with
something you want to walk around with
dynamite instead of TNT I mean I guess I
wouldn't do either but go ahead and Matt
that explains why the coyote always
blows up because it's it's TNT instead
of dynamite I remember that now he
should have he should have spoken
foolish didn't study didn't study enough
all right well I I'm again I love
combining questions because James Hall
from Texas says I'm wondering about
chemistry signs of extraterrestrial life
are we able to see enough chemistry in
exoplanet atmospheres to ask if they
have to know if they have similar
pollution from burning fossil fuels for
example CFCs and then this is why I
asked that one first before I moved on
to Richard Hart's question from
Richard's nine-year-old daughter Kyrene
who says what kind of chemistry is
happening in your body to cause you to
toot she wants to know if tooting is
just you tooting out bacteria toots I'm
curious if these quote bacteria toots as
she calls them are what scientists are
looking for in the search for life on
other worlds oh my gosh oh my God
okay there you go it's in your lap now
you I'll defer to Kate on this way okay
all right okay so let's start with the
Extraterrestrial part so the question
was would we predict the same pollutants
in other areas my response would be it
depends on the atmosphere of that planet
and so here on Earth we have oxygen and
so when we burn fossil fuels we form
carbon dioxide and that's what's causing
climate change and so if these other
planets had oxygen in their environment
then yes I would predict that CO2 would
be formed if they burned something
that's a hydrocarbon I also want to fact
check what was just said CFCs are not
generated in a typical combustion
reaction yes they contribute to climate
change they are greenhouse gas but it's
not necessarily a byproduct of
combustion CFC chlorine or fluorocarbons
right chlorofluorocarbons yeah those are
the ones that were banned back in the
80s when uh the ozone hole was getting
really big and a big piece of it is
because they have a global warming
potential of about 8 000 I think the
number is like 8100 whereas carbon
dioxide has a global warming potential
of one and we're terrified of what
carbon dioxide is doing and that has
level one CFCs have 8100 so it's pretty
extreme
okay and then okay now how about tooting
so that has to do with what's in your
body and so essentially what you eat is
then broken down in our stomach we have
a bunch of different versions of acid
it's essentially hydrochloric acid and
some kind of derivatives of it and so
the acid goes in your acid likes to
donate a proton and so it's going to
react with what other molecules are that
you just ate and you're breaking down
those species and then tooting them out
and so your toots could be composed of a
number of different things based on what
you've digested so could we find life on
another planet based on farts I'm going
with yes if you somehow have a bucket of
farts then yeah we could probably figure
that out but no but the real question is
and I'm sure Matt is thinking this he
just doesn't want to ask it
um can't our our toots
flammable
absolutely this is the Old Camp question
okay yeah when you go to be careful
about rocket exhaust in the vicinity of
a gaseous person
yes
I guess yes
what is it that's in the tooth that's
flammable what what chemical
two main primary ones would be methane
um and so we know that from cows when
cows are eating their Foods they're
pushing out a lot of methane so they're
I know methane just comes out of my
stove that's my yes yes that's my
smoking gas okay and what else that's
CH4 and so that's extremely flammable
um and then another part of it and it's
a very small portion of it is hydrogen
sulfide and that's quite flammable as
well the sulfur typically has a rotten
egg smell and so if your your farts ever
smell egg-ish there's likely a sulfur
somewhere in your farts
does Methane itself have a smell because
if it doesn't then everything we
attribute to the smell of art would be
the hydrogen sulfide is that right
yes yes I mean methane is definitely
odorless there's no color or anything
like that so I would say I feel
comfortable telling you that methane
you're not going to smell it but you're
you're pushing out a lot of things
100 sulfur
okay yeah
all right I don't I don't know that we
can follow that with another question
okay
let's leave that one exactly where it is
uh and thank Kate oh my gosh thank you
for this and I like I said we don't do
enough chemistry on this program and
chemistry is everywhere at all times and
and your Kate the chemist so I don't
want to pass up any possible future
opportunities to bring you back and so
when you're deep embedded in your new
podcast
um we'll give you another call to come
back and talk about how that's going and
maybe tell us about some of your
favorite guests that you've had
you can't pick favorites so they're all
my favorites
we'll pick a favorite that's right
that's fair that's right I'll let you do
that all right and Matt always good to
have you there that's my co-host so good
and thank you to the patreon patrons and
there were so many great questions we
didn't get a chance to get to so you're
gonna have to have more chemists and
more more of Kate on soon yeah
definitely we'll miss out on that
opportunity this has been Star Talk
Cosmic queries the chemicals Edition I'm
Neil deGrasse Tyson here your personal
physicist as always to keep looking up
foreign
[Music]